this device right here is the future of
mobile gaming on the iphone and not only
because i think this is quite literally
the best solution for a gaming
controller for a mobile device like an
iphone or an android device but also
because this is literally the direction
that apple is headed with their own
patents that they have already filed so
before we get into some real world
gameplay of some of the best mobile
games out there showing you guys the
best features of the backbone one and
why i think it's the best controller you
can get for mobile gaming i wanna
explain what apple is gonna be doing in
the future and why this is the closest
thing that we can experience right now
before apple's solution comes out in the
future for years now we've been hearing
leaks and rumors that apple is gonna be
working on their own actual gaming
controller from multiple sources like
love to dream fudge and others but now
we finally have some confirmation that
apple is getting closer and closer to
releasing their own gaming controller
yes we recently got some patents showing
off some different ways that apple can
create a game controller and one of them
is actually in the style of a nintendo
switch where you have controls on both
sides of your iphone that sits in the
middle exactly like this backbone one
but wait it gets even better because we
got even more patents showing that apple
could be using magnets or in other words
their new magsafe technology to connect
the iphone to a new gaming controller
that has controls on the side which is
exactly what i think apple is gonna be
doing and with that said let's finally
get into reviewing the backbone one and
playing some actual games on it but
before i get into the games i wanna show
you guys the design because this thing
is incredible first of all it's very
lightweight and as you can see it is
very very slim and this backbone right
here is very low profile so it's pretty
convenient looking at the top we have
both l1 l2 r1 and r2 buttons right here
so you can use these as the triggers and
you can use these buttons for whatever
you want to map them to going over here
we have this layout of two joysticks
which is very convenient for first of
all moving around and looking around we
have these general buttons and of course
we have these for everything else that
you want to do including some menu
buttons and everything else and the way
this works is you basically pull on it
and it opens up to a massive size to
basically support any kind of phone you
would like and this one of course is
with a lightning port so it's meant for
iphones all you do is you grab your
iphone and i actually have a skin on and
it works with the skin you basically
just line up the lightning connector
just like this open it up
bam
there you go you are done and ready to
go all right here we go and as you can
see there's this little controller icon
showing that it automatically detected
that we're using a controller and if you
really want to you can go into the
settings go over to the controller and
map out all the controls and buttons
that you want which is very nice but as
i get into a match the beauty of the
backbone one is that it does not have
any batteries at all so it is literally
powered by your iphone which is good for
a couple of different things first of
all it means that you have a latency
free experience so there's no dealing
with bluetooth connections or with a
battery that dies it literally just gets
powered by the iphone and it's a
hardwired connection so it's not going
through the air that means you're
getting the most reliable connection
possible
all right so i'm used to playing this
with my
hands
so it does take a little bit of practice
but once you get it man this is
convenient i love how just responsive
these controls are and i love how
everything's connected you know so you
have your display
right in the middle and the reason
that's important is because
with other setups
if you have a separate controller like
an xbox controller in your hands you
kind of have to move your iphone around
and set it up on some kind of stand but
literally the controller is the stand it
holds everything up
and you get a nice immersive display
right in front of you and the beauty of
that
is you could literally oh i hear a guy
the beauty of that is that you can
literally
walk around your house while playing
of course man this thing is lightweight
i love that it's slim because other
things like the uh the razer kishi that
is quite a bit larger i mean this makes
it so much easier to aim to be honest
like this kind of gives you a
competitive
advantage this is so amazing like this
beats the xbox controller you got no
batteries got no bluetooth connection
it's wired all the time powered by your
iphone but check this out you might be
wondering what happens if you're running
low on battery well this thing actually
comes with a pass-through
lightning charging port watch this you
can see lightning port
right here and boom
it is charging
that is amazing but wait
it gets better you know why because this
thing actually has
a headphone jack now i know a lot of you
guys have air pods already but just in
case you still have some of these wired
headphones i was able to find these ones
let's see if it actually works
so you can hear the audio
yep it works
i can't believe it this is so awesome
all right so the experience on call of
duty mobile was pretty good let's
actually test out genshin impact and see
how that is with the backbone one as you
can see i'm in the settings i'm going to
switch to controller support working
perfectly and i just love that it does
not rely on batteries so you're getting
a hard wired connection with no latency
i think that's the best part so as you
can see i'm going in here and
i just have all these convenient
controls look at that
so that is pretty awesome but i'm not
against an impact player so let's go and
play some of that new apex legends now
that i'm here in apex legends i do want
to point out another awesome feature
because this backbone is so slim you
actually can easily use the touchscreen
just like that
while you have the backbone on so it's
actually convenient because some of
these games like call of duty mobile and
apex they don't really support the
controllers in terms of the actual ui or
the load screen while you're doing stuff
so if you had a controller in your hands
then you had to go back to your display
to go through the menus and stuff that's
kind of inconvenient but check it out
i'm holding the backbone and i can
easily
just use
use it just like that so this is awesome
i just love this and i just love playing
on the iphone because in apex
you actually get
80 fps mode
[Applause]
got a
it's a little hard to get used to the
aiming in this game
wait i ran out
i got no ammos man
got him
got him
yes
i also love how when you're not actually
using it it folds down and it's just so
compact and lightweight you can throw it
into any bag or wherever you want
got them
yes got him
is that like a bob dude that guy was
just running around we did it though
i mean this is just the most convenient
gaming controller i just can't
stress that enough it's low profile it's
hardware based so hardwired
no batteries
no bluetooth no latency it's got
everything you need
pass-through charging headphone jack i
mean i love this thing 100 on amazon
it's a little bit pricey but man so
honestly if i was going to give this
thing a rating it would probably be
around 9 out of 10 because so far
everything's been working great i
haven't really noticed any flaws it's
lightweight fits perfectly hardwired
i just love it so i think i'm going to
continue to use this thing for any type
of mobile gaming that supports
controllers and i would recommend it to
anybody who is considering getting a
controller because i would much rather
buy this thing than some kind of xbox
bluetooth controller with batteries you
don't have to worry about anything like
that with this thing and you can
literally walk around your house
anywhere you want to go with this
controller or on the bus wherever i love
it so hopefully you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe definitely
check out one of those two videos right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video